تنكيل بالاحياء وتمثيل بجثث الشهداء هذا
ما كشفه تحقيق للجزيره عن انتهاكات
ارتكبها الجيش الاسرائيلي لعشرات من
الفلسطينيين في غزه بينهم اطفال التحقيق
شامل مقطعا يعود الى الحدي من اكتوبر
تشرين الاول الماضي اظهر جنودا يسحلون
شبابا مقيدي الايدي والارجل تركوا في
العراء ساعات وعند مقارنه المقطع متداول
بمقطع اخر تبين ان زي الجنود وحذائه
وقبعات يتطابق مع زي جنود اخرين من لواء
كفير احد اكبر الويه الدفاع الاسرائيليه
فيديو اخر يعود الى ال9 من اكتوبر ايضا
اظهر جنديا اسرائيليا يربط قدمي شهيد
فلسطيني بحبل وبعدها جرته عربه مدرعه على
تربه صحراويه صور الانتهاكات عرضت على
مركز للطب الشرعي اكد ان بعض الجثث لذكور
في العقد الثاني من العمر تتراوح اعمارهم
بين 10 اعوام و15 عاما المقاطع اظهرت ان
المعتقلين لم يكونوا مسلحين ولم يكن في
حوزتهم اسلحه او ازياء ومستلزمات عسكريه
المشاهد عدت انتهاكا صارخا للقوانين
الدوليه التي تنص على ضرور حمايه المدنيين
في
الحروب